and the nominees for best new YouTube
channel are Wyoming girl 23 X X Mega Man
X X the film theorist you see lowercase
o IV five one four five evn lowercase e
lowercase F eight winner is
you see lowercase o underscore IV five
one four five
totally deserved it
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where the true
prize is knowledge ah am I kidding give
me that hundred twenty thousand dollar
gift bag already
oh don't worry Angelina Jolie you can
keep your $250 Laser vibrator the luxury
condom and the $20,000 tarot card
reading I'm only in it for the four
thousand dollars worth of liposuction
this felt figure ain't maintaining
itself my friends I ain't gettin any
thinner sitting at my desk making
YouTube videos I'll tell you that much
so if I'm gonna get my gift certificate
to dr. Dave's fat vacuum Emporium I need
to figure out a way to win myself an
Oscar but how well the thing to remember
is that like most things in life the
Academy Awards are again a system and as
such there are hacks exploits loopholes
that begin to show themselves if you
look close enough and that's the job of
this show look at the facts figure out
the trends so that I can tell you you
win an Oscar and in the process finally
get your parents to stop hounding you
for your feet or degree so after
scouring 87 years worth of nominee and
winner data believe it or not each
category has its own clear formula for
winning sure it's not as exact as one
plus one equals two but today we're
going to increase your odds tremendously
with the help of some hard facts graphs
and bad jokes courtesy of yours truly
now let the odds be ever in your favor
first things first we got to get
ourselves nominated but it can't be that
hard to get on the ballot right right
well in order to beat the system we need
to understand the system there are
nearly sixty three hundred members of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences the guys who are voting to get
nominees on the ballot those sixty three
hundred are divided into seventeen
branches some branches you would expect
like writers directors and actors others
like public relations casting directors
and executives not so much they all go
through two rounds of voting the first
time members can only vote in their own
category and this creates a nominee list
and then a month later everyone votes
again but this time in every category to
pick the winners the one exception to
this best
picture Best Picture nominees are voted
on by everyone both times so if you're
looking to land a nomination know who
you're playing to Oscar voters are 94%
white 77% male and they have a median
age of 62 which means any movie
mentioning their favorite childhood
pastime of hoops and sticks in the
street is going to get bonus points
conversely anything involving modern
technology a social network
may get a nomination just so that the
gray hairs voting can look hip and cool
but when it comes to winning yeah you're
out of luck they actually had no clue
what your movie was about and to round
out our voter statistics 33 percent of
voting members are former nominees 14
percent are former winners and 22
percent are actors keep that one in mind
now you can already start to predict how
some of these trends are going to affect
our winners but hold on there horses or
I suppose if you're John Travolta hold
on to adele dazeem space because we're
gonna go one step deeper and pick apart
the awards category by category and
let's start with the biggie what it
takes to win Best Picture since you know
go big or go home
so right off the bat I have two words
for you that will increase your odds of
getting a nomination immediately true
story as we get closer to 2015 movies
based on a true story have swept the
Oscars
starting with Million Dollar Baby and
going up to 12 years of slave seven out
of ten oscar-winning movies in the
category of Best Picture belong to the
true story group actually you can make
it 8 out of 11 because even though it
may not say at Birdman this year's
winner is also based on a true story for
those of you who haven't seen this
pretty artsy film it's about an actor
who used to play the role of an animal
themed superhero before his career
petered out the movie then follows his
quest to revive it now switch to the
true story element the movie stars
Michael Keaton who played Batman an
animal themed superhero before his
career just kind of petered out now he's
old and is using this movie to try and
revive his career that is far more based
on a true story than old plastic baby
over here well plastic baby brings up a
good point look at what else was
nominated practically all of them were
based on real
it's American sniper the story of US
Navy SEAL sharpshooter Chris Kyle the
imitation game about wartime code
breaker Alan Turing Stephen Hawking
biopic the theory of everything
Selma about Martin Luther King's civil
rights marches boyhood which may not
have been based on a true story but did
feature 12 years of a real growing up
family experience and whiplash whose
story was inspired by the directors time
spent playing in a very competitive jazz
band I would make a joke about very
competitive jazz bands is like ooh watch
out that muted trumpets gonna get you
but I was in a very competitive show
choir throughout high school so I feel
like I have no room to judge but look at
that nominee list
it leaves grand Budapest hotel as the
only purely fictional movie nominated
this year let's go back to last year
American hustle captain Phillips Dallas
buyers club Philomena 12 years of slave
and the wolf of Wall Street again all
based on true stories that is 6 out of 9
it's an incredibly powerful trend right
now but if you want to go the extra mile
and really ensure your chance at a
golden statue don't just make it a true
story make it a true story that occurred
during the Holocaust Schindler's List
about a Nazi businessman who saves his
Jewish workers was nominated for 12
awards back in 1993 then went on to go
home with seven Meryl Streep received
her second Oscar for 1982's Sophie's
Choice about a woman haunted by her time
in a concentration camp and Roman
Polanski's the pianist won three awards
in 2002 from the seven categories it was
nominated in in fact the trend is so
strong get this when Kate Winslet was a
guest star on Ricky Gervais C's extras
this is what she had to say now I'm
doing it because I've noticed that if
you do filmed a Holocaust guaranteed an
Oscar I've been nominated four times
never won the whole world is going why
hasn't wins that one one death yet so
here's a question is the joke on us or
on Hollywood cuz Kate Winslet finally
won her award for her performance in
2009 the reader a film about you guessed
it the Holocaust she
he figured out the formula so clearly
people have caught wise onto this period
piece based on a sad true story trend
and are exploiting the ever-loving
bejesus out of it thank you very much
Weinstein's so I'm gonna give you the
secret on how to make an award-winner
that doesn't instantly reek of pandering
answer me this what does the Academy
love more than world war 2 itself
remember the entirety of award season is
about the film industry patting itself
on the back and recently Oscars ego has
only gotten bigger and more shameless in
the last four years look at what's won
the big prize movies about how great
movies are and not just movies but
specifically how great actors are
seriously three out of the last four
Best Picture winners are about how
wonderful and important actors are
there's the artist about the birth of
sound pictures and the struggle silent
film actors went through in making the
transition Birdman
who's deeper meaning is a video for
another day but at its core is a
commentary on the artistic purity of
acting and most blatantly of all or go
about how a bunch of actors save the CIA
by rescuing hostages in Iran remember
when I said that 22% of the Academy
voters are actors know your audience
loyal theorists know your audience and
it makes even more sense when you look
at the other big common thread across
Best Picture movies their vehicles
specifically for the actors look at
gravity it won seven awards the most
awards of 2013 Best Director
cinematography visual effects editing
score sound editing and sound mixing
notice that it didn't win any acting
awards and that it didn't win Best
Picture despite having the most awards
of the year and the Best Director how
about the year where both inception and
social network were nominated both big
idea movies with cutting edge effects
unique screenplays visionary direction
both winning a lot of technical awards
but ultimately losing the big prize to
the King's Speech a period piece
spotlighting two of the industry's most
beloved actors remember when everyone
thought that avatar was a lock for Best
Picture because of its cutting edge use
of CGI and 3d well that 22 percent of
the voters didn't take too kindly to
computer and
made it Smurfs doing the acting for them
and the award went to the small human
war drama known as The Hurt Locker
Birdman yep a tour de force for its
actors talking about acting you could
literally make a drinking game out of
this okay so you took my advice and
filmed the next Citizen Kane well don't
do that since it didn't win despite
being hailed as the greatest movie of
all time
we'll get there another day let me start
that again so you film some shamelessly
dramatic period piece with actors
chewing the scenery congratulations
time to edit the footage my advice here
don't leave too much on the editing
floor since Best Picture winners tend to
be longer than your average film your
average film over the last decade has
been about 85 minutes long your Oscar
Best Picture winner is at minimum two
hours looking at the data 70% of all
Best Picture winners are longer than two
hours over the films released after 1960
that number jumps up to 80% the shortest
Best Picture winner of all time marty
was only 91 minutes and that's very much
the exception Gone with the Wind Ben Hur
Lawrence of Arabia all tip the
three-and-a-half hour mark if you
include the intermissions yes so long
that they need intermissions Return of
the King is just under three hours and
21 minutes
in fact there's definitely length bias
Oscar voters like to give the award to
the longest movie nominated for each set
of nominees we rank the movies by
runtime the longest nominee has won Best
Picture more than 40 percent of the time
so if you're thinking of making your
director's cut anything under 4 hours
you're doing something wrong my friends
so well done if you followed my advice
at this point you should be holding the
perfect Oscar bait masterpiece but don't
drop the ball in the homestretch you
still have to release this thing and
like in comedy timing is every if you
want to win an Oscar release it late in
the year
this strategic releasing means that
Academy voters are more likely to have a
fresh memory of your movie it's a
psychological phenomenon called the
recency effect plus the film is still
being featured in the press when they're
casting the votes thing we took a look
at the 97 films nominated at the Oscars
between 2000 and 2013 it turns out that
56% of films nominated for Best Picture
at the Academy Awards were first
released in the u.s. in either November
or December over
half in the last two months of the year
so that's a lot of information let's
recap in short if you want to go balls
to the wall and give yourself the
absolute best chance at winning an Oscar
find an inspiring true story of a
Holocaust victim who was an actor and/or
director who courageously used that gift
to make the world a better place then
make sure that your stars have nice
juicy roles keep the runtime above two
hours and release it in November
voila you have just done everything in
your power to optimize your movie to win
an Oscar but you know what internet here
on film theory I'm not going to be
content just giving you the formula for
the most tantalizing Oscar bait all of
you film students watching I will
outright give you the movie you have to
make in order to practically guarantee
yourself Oscar gold the true story of
Kurt Gerron
Kurt Gerron was a German Jewish actor
and film director born into a wealthy
merchant family in Berlin he served in
World War one but after being severely
wounded became a military doctor instead
after the war he entered the world of
theater starring in the first ever
production of the Threepenny Opera one
of the most famous stage pieces you've
probably never heard of originating
classic songs that have transcended
generations most famously Mack the Knife
and get this Kurt Gerron was the first
ever to perform that song and as
Threepenny achieved international
success Gerrans performance of the song
became famous across Europe this
propelled him into the world of cinema
starring opposite Marlene Dietrich in
1930s the Blue Angel but then shortly
thereafter the Nazis began to take power
though his actor and director friends
offered him an escape to Hollywood Kurt
refused to leave Europe he was
eventually captured by the Nazis and
sent to a concentration camp where he
was forced to put together stage
cabarets for the German prison guards
including reprising his famous
performance of man
in 1944 the Nazis made him direct a
propaganda film about the humane
conditions of the internment camps and
when the film was finished
Geron was deported to Auschwitz where he
and his troupe of musicians and actors
were immediately sent to the gas
chambers upon their arrival and killed
and if that wasn't sad enough in a
tragic twist his train was the last one
between his camp and ouch wits and the
gas chambers were ordered to be closed
for good the very day after his
execution tragic certainly Oscar gold
you bet now when you see this one pop up
in the next few years you know where the
idea started right here and you my
friends were a part of it and hey if
you're the one making it and you don't
win an Oscar don't come to me you only
have yourself to blame and if you're
interested to see what it takes to win
the acting awards click here to see our
episode on those guys because there are
some weird things going on there the
dark twisted politics of awards season
my friends it's a strange place
anyway hopefully I'll see you over there
on that episode but if not remember it's
all just a theory
all film theory and cut welcome back to
the super amazing n card tournament
where I encourage you to subscribe
because honestly I really want this
channel to be successful and if you've
made it this far into the video chances
are you liked what you saw so it only
makes logical sense for you to hit that
button right now right now right okay
great now it's your turn to join the
Academy cast your vote of the following
movies who would you give the best
picture award to guardians of the galaxy
Hunger Games Mockingjay The Hobbit
Battle of five armies or interstellar
are you going to go with the super
popular guardians between age hit
Katniss the really long conclusion to
the really long trilogy of movies to the
really short book The Hobbit or
interstellar where the fifth dimension
is love click on one to choose be taking
the channel page check out some more of
our new videos and hopefully hopefully
let me plug it one more time you should
probably subscribe